l'origine de tout cela tient en un seul
mot un nom ce nom c'est votre boulot ou
blu c'est pourquoi l'on gagne un garçon
qui se trouvait là que nous voyons
quelquefois s'approche mais une main ici
un pied là qui se dresse sur le sommet
sans que nous ayons compris par quelle
astuce magique
il y était parvenu c'est ainsi que j'ai
fait la connaissance de piranha au nom
du président de la république et en
vertu des pouvoirs qui lui sont conférés
je vous fait officier de la légion
d'honneur
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour cette cérémonie et
puis bon ami marcel ishaq pense et
ressent dans le béa
c'est avec quoi éveiller à jean yanne un
chèque et voilà son frère à tanger je
vais regarder passer ces deux là ont des
parcours faisait grimper
et bien voilà on grimpait par exemple à
la presta tu te souviens quand l'école
pour calade que beaucoup de nos
meilleurs grimpeurs ont fait leurs
premiers pas hier à la mine ity jacques
hossaert en techniques du rocher
d'immenses il se dit là quelqu'un dire
éditions ne se fait pas au hasard parmi
les procédés employés
l'opposition est le plus pratique
l'effort des gens s'opposent celui les
bras il le graveur progresse ainsi à la
façon du singe sur accompagner
[Musique]
vous
la technique de l'adhérence permet de se
maintenir sur un rocher vis en défiant
les lois de l'équilibré
pierre que ce d'élèves apel muller dire
aussi semble se jouer des dividendes
ce maître qui a gravi le sommet de
l'himalaya à qui sa virtuosité en
s'entraînant pendant debitel sur les
branches et européennes
il
[Musique]
dans les années 30 rue bay avait
programmes tels que au maximum quelques
dizaines de grimpeur
je rappelle surtout du côté du cuvier
grimpe et non pas comme des forcenés mon
grand père parce que ça me faisait
plaisir sans espèces de l'esprit de
compétition après c'est venu font
grimper simplement pour ceux pour le
plaisir de grimper
[Musique]
brillante et de la difficulté en
utilisant les moindres aspérités en
conservant l'adhérence rend tout prix
semble avoir disparu lui laisse glisser
quand même coûte que coûte
tel est le but laddh
[Musique]
qui avait sauvé la division
l'appellation des gens selon leur degré
qui franchissait à blu ray c'est à dire
que le premier degré ont appelé
lamentable débris le deuxième demi
finale 2 2 c'était des pompes corniaud
le troisième c'était le temps des
squares popiste le quatrième s'était
déjà l'honorable un peu le choc je parle
des degrés blu ray bien sûr le 5e
c'était le puissant seigneur du drap
temps et enfin le 6e c'était la pure
lumière des roches à la fiole nuage et
moi ah ben moi je t'ai la très vieille
et très pure lumière des rochers non me
souviens que les plus doués la 2 qui
était arrivé à faire avec ce qui oblige
quand mais je peux te donner quelques
conseils
oui alors non des as tu es tu t'es mal
je te dis que je te dirai est là on va
leur faire comme ça voilà le pire ici
c'est ce qui incite avait des skis quand
tu prends bien de là car sur l'institut
tient mieux sur ces petites président et
la queue plate le rocher doucement pour
trouver une fissure aimable et si si tu
montes ton pied dans certaines missions
le v3 mais c'était c'est pas mal il
était pas mais la prochaine fois tu
viens d'acter ce titre essaiera c'est
peut-être mieux pour les petites prises
latéral et puis après les pieds là
dessus voilà oui je me souviens mais
c'est ça mais il ya la prise que tu as
remarqué
président koala oui oui alors là il ya
une bonne prise mais il faut pas la
louper
alors à huy partir à droite la suivre la
pratique de la vire à droite s'il ya des
des prises à la relativement facile
alors c'est après pour sortir parce que
moi j'ai pas le droit de santé un tas
pas droit non
en principe oui je connais mais je suis
pas bien placé à ils ont bien fait droit
c'était la main droite qu'il fallait
tu sais mon vieux moi je ne m'en
souviens plus
bah c'est bien et je crois à taux plein
et demain peut plus voir là à vue voilà
épié pu voilà et après après et là il
faut montrer qu'ils ont fait ça marche
ouf on pense tu sais pourquoi tu parles
je suis lourdaud cette fois yable
qu'elle avait froid ya 76
enfin bon c'est le passé mon dieu
qu'est-ce qui me font pas peur
habituellement tout au moins jusqu en 37
j'étais toujours devant parce que
c'était moi qui avais l'idée qu'ils
partaient qu'il proposait de terrain
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait que la face
nord des drus n'a été faite pendant
trente-cinq parce qu en 33 j'ai trouvé
personne
isabelle parize dégonflé puis pensais
que c'était un fougueux les les
entraîner dans des aventures un possible
alors en 34 il y avait mauvais temps et
autrement charrues quelqu'un ja rule
jean ménager en 35 jean faisait son
service militaire est resté raymond
alors c'est pour ça qu'on est parti de
deux créneaux et puis on était dans la
vallée quand tout d'un coup des copains
nous disent lambert et au 2 rue ça l'est
encore les drames lambert est au 2 rue
ils sont remontés montenvers toute
allure et laon avec une des jumelles on
a vu nos lascars qui était en train de
progresser dans la face alors quand on a
vu qu'il s'arrêtait et que même il
commence à redescendre
pousser un soupir de soulagement dit le
plus dur est fait maintenant il ya plus
qu'à y aller finir la corde et alain
reininger très entraînés parvient
rapidement pied des difficultés qui ont
repoussé le suisse lambert elle se
présente sous forme d'une double
fissures verticale de 40 m pierre sur sa
quincaillerie python mousquetons marteau
il par une main dans chaque fissure les
pieds en opposition sur la dalle il
suffisait d'avoir un navet des
espadrilles avait pas les espadrilles
c'était des sortes de basket parce qu'à
ce moment là il ya une chose dont
escalade n'existait pas ce qui est
beaucoup plus léger beaucoup plus
agréable et beaucoup plus d'adhérence à
garder cet avantage pour la stella
trancheuse
la technique de l'adhérence mise au
point à fontainebleau fait merveille
elle leur permet de surmonter toutes les
difficultés le passage clé surnommé
fissures alain restera longtemps
considéré comme le plus dur du massif du
mont blanc
de nos jours les cordes et évite la
fissure alain en passant par une autre
plus facile découverte plus tard
[Musique]
au passage délicat clés de la tension
pierre passe aisément la fissure elle
paraît presque facile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après deux jours passés dans la face
nord pierre alain et raymond leininger
atteint enfin le sommet des drus
enfin tous les efforts troublant
récompense c'est la minute deux fois la
fierté de la difficulté vaincus se mêle
à la grandeur du spectacle
l'alpiniste n'est plus qu'une petite
chose perdue dans la chine des finances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le succès retentissant de cette première
fille terre les chamoniards sceptiques
qui ne comprenait pas comment ces jeunes
parisiens aux s affronter à de telles
paroisse j'ai jusqu'à lors impossible au
montant vers il y avait quelques
personnes qui étaient là bas il y en a
un qu'il disait mais vous êtes sûr que
vous allez vous pouvoir panser ses
terres à d'autres qui nous disait si
vous revenez ramener vivant alors bien
jusqu'à la seconde guerre
pierre-alain continuera sur sa lancée en
effectuant une quantité incroyable de
premières ascensions dont la célèbre
face sud de la meije avec lui toujours
le même souci révolutionner l'équipement
réservé aux alpinistes
il invente tour à tour le sac de
couchage et la veste on dirait bien plus
chaude et plus légère que la veste en
drap de bonneval le mousqueton léger qui
remplace le mousqueton acier beaucoup
trop long
il crée également le descendeur petit
appareil destiné à éviter les brûlures
parfois douloureuse de la descente en
rappel sur la crise
[Musique]
enfin pour remplacer les vétustes
trikini le premier chaussons d'escaladé
appelait encore à l'heure actuelle béa
et initiale le piranha
en 1936 pierre est sélectionnée parmi
l'élite de l'alpinisme français pour
partir en himalaya en 36 c'est la
première expédition française qui était
commandée par un rite sega nous étions
dix français des sherpas et puis 500
porteurs du pays + 300 porteurs du pays
pour nourrir les 500 sur le glacier où
il y avait plus de ravitaillement signe
ce qui faisait un moment d'aller étions
buisson reçoit les par l'extraordinaire
ben
en riz de ségou y raconte de ce séjour
je ne me souviens guère que les
sentiments d'admiration pour ceux de mes
camarades qui sans redescendre une seule
fois au camp de base reste r 25 jours de
suite en haute altitude et lutter d'une
lutte souvent pénibles et périlleuse
pour le succès de l'expédition
je revois ces journées demeurions
confinés sous les tentes
le sommeil était notre seul bien-être
mais on ne peut pas dormir dans le
grondement des avalanches
et que font-ils là haut
enfin une note de pierre-alain m'apporte
des nouvelles le froid avait atteint -20
degrés la violence du vent était telle
qu'ils étaient obligés au camp 5 de se
cramponner roma de la tante de crainte
qu'elle soit emportée
quelques jours plus tard la tempête
n'avait pas cessé ce fut l'évacuation
définitive
l'écroulement d'un rêve du moins à
défaut de la victoire espérée gagnons
nous la certitude d'une revanche futur
malheureusement pour pierre et ses amis
l'arrivée de la guerre empêchera tout
nouveau projet pierre-alain participera
à la libération de chamonix mais c'est à
paris que le parfum de liberté retrouvée
lui donnera de nouvelles idées et
quelques piques à vagues en voir et en
plein champs elysées chemine est propre
bien et cordes de montagne si vous
voulez bien ce sera le début de notre
histoire et avant d'aller plus loin
permettez moi de vous présenter nos
quatre amis et râle un jeu venait
remettre aux grimpeurs
je voulais ni le gros con éperlecques le
dur et jacques boissinot le benjamin
messieurs vous voudrez ça me plaît
[Musique]
jésus maintenant de suivre nos quatre
alpinistes
j'avais une ascension plus ordinaire
cette bonne tour eiffel ne se doute pas
de ce qui a germé dans les têtes de nos
montagnards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant ce temps l'hôtel venus eux s'en
donnent à coeur joie sur les parois de
l'éguille eiffel ferrone parce que nous
ne suffisent d'approché de supplanter et
on est tranquille et prisca spawn
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même pour quatre alpinistes très
entraînante franche et c'est encore
bellemans à 300 mètres au dessus du sol
c'est une opération délicate
particulièrement vertigineuse le vide
est ici beaucoup plus impressionnant
dans montagne il est partout à la fois
jusqu au travers même des poutrelles
[Musique]
le dernier surplombe la tour eiffel
monde comme ça alors là il y avait un
tuyau annonce est pris aux tuyaux depuis
à l'envi dans le marché en est arrivé là
où ça a été le bouvier le curieux c'est
justement au troisième étage parce que
jean il savait pas n'était pas averti
y avez vous voyez bien un cameraman qui
étaient là ont trente ans de quelque
chose me semble par contre alors ils
nous ont vu surgir tout évident delà de
l'art en bar blues pas je ne voyais
arriver demain ça a été assez surpris
mais la plateforme n'est pas le seul
mais il reste encore quelques mètres
d'eux pétrolière jusqu'à la rampe du
drapeau jeu dernier peloton à plus de
300 m 2 sud paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
c'est moi
kg
oh non non
on a dévoyé de porc
les jetons
[Musique]
non
il
baj
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
combien de temps que j'ai sauvé ailleurs
chaque matin
c'est sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
cette fameuse qui sera non ça donne quoi
un vol bien
m
ça me désole c'est pas content du tout
d'abord on ne reconnaît pas tout de
suite parce que
je tiens à quelques matelas oui mais
faut reconnaître les lieux ça prend un
certain temps
c'est un petit coup au coeur quand même
non un de revoir cette voie comme ça
politiquement il j'aurais peut-être oui
la fin à cinquante ans ont passé
oui un canton exactement oui quelques
jeux peluches quelques jours 35 31
juillet ouais c'est important du 1er
août
un seul big mac et iphone a qui font pas
mieux mais c'est une superbe au moins
nous on était passé justement par cette
fissure alain ce qu'ils font et est
inconcevable attendu oui je contentait
d'une loi générale mais pas plusieurs la
suite les unes des autres
non mais j'ai tout à fait autre chose
parce que l'on était des vrais amateurs
dans ce sens que l'on travaillait
semaine qui était dépendant pendant
cette année je veux dire on centrale est
un peu à fontainebleau le dimanche
seulement
et puis c'était les vacances pendant les
vacances consistait pas en faire le
maximum c'est à dire ah c'était les
vacances
[Musique]
cette idée de vacances est la notion de
plaisir même était tout à fait
révolutionnaire à l'époque la montagne
apparaissait bien plus souvent comme une
source permanente de danger que
l'alpiniste se devait affronter
il n'est plus à fond lève est inquiet en
des temps le midi dac voudrais bien mais
je ne peux pas répondre à cet accord
stipule que derrière avec refus impact
pourrait pas durer
[Musique]
fatigué par ses efforts idylis jacques a
tenu la corde aussi
la leçon est sévère attention nerveux
s'ajoute à la fatigue
[Musique]
pourtant nous en présente une s'avoue
pas vaincu et j'essaie de tourner la
difficulté en 106 ans d'un couloir mais
l'apprenti solennelle manque et c'est le
deuxième essai
[Musique]
de mai à août
c'est une double page à face de chaque
côté d'une autre époque
ces machines elles se trouvent dans le
problème
[Musique]
oui
on a parlé ici ici c'est donc l'atelier
dans lequel on fait les finitions enfin
différentes opérations avant le montage
fond c'est quoi le rappelle c'est pour
garder la forme il faut pas se laisser
rouiller les épaules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]